[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me souviens du bord de mer avec ces
filles auain si clair elles avaient
l'âme hospitalière c'était pas fait pour
nous
déplaire naïve autant qu'elles étaient
belles on pouvait lire dans leur brunell
qu'ell voulaient pratiquer le sport pour
garder une belle ligne de corps et
encore et
encore j'aurais pu danser la
java Ctait chouette les filles du bon
de Ctait chouette pour qui savait
fa en avait une qui s'appelaitve c'était
vraiment la fine des rêve elle n'avait
qu'un seul défaut plus qu'il ne
faut plutôt que d'aller chez le maassur
elleit le premier baigneur à TTI du côté
de son cœur en douceur en
douceur en douceur et
profondeur Z chouette les filles du
[Applaudissements]
bordain
ch pour qui
[Applaudissements]
SAV pardonnant cette manie tu propose
partager ma vie mais dès que rev l'été
je commençais à
m'inquiéter car sur les bord de la mer
du Nord elle se remit à faire du sport
je ce viingre sinon devenait
malingre
puis en Beaujour j'en ai eu Mar c'était
pire que la mer à boire il l'ffilé un
gigolo et j'ai nagé vers
[Musique]
d'autres C chouette les
du FA qui sa le
[Musique]
FL